police are investigating a possible hate
crime against NBA superstar LeBron James
the LAPD said someone spray-painted the
n-word across the front gate of his Los
Angeles mansion it was quickly removed
James and his family were not there at
the time Dana Jacobson shows us his
reaction ahead of Game one of the NBA
Finals tonight they know good morning
good morning Charlie LeBron James has
never been one to shy away from
commenting on social issues especially
racism and with this latest incident
impacting James directly it comes as no
surprise that he addressed the issue
head-on reminding us that even he
doesn't feel equal in America no matter
how much money you have no matter how
famous you are no matter how many people
admire you you know being being black in
America is it's tough and we got a long
way to go the day before Game one of the
NBA Finals LeBron James struck a
sobering tone about race in America
after police say someone spray-painted
the n-word on the front gate of his Los
Angeles home Wednesday morning racism
will always be a part of the world a
part of America and you know hate you
know in America especially for African
American is living every day unlike
other contemporary superstars the 3-time
NBA champion has been vocal about social
issues LeBron has never lost track of
being black in America and I think that
what he said the day was very profound
veteran columnist bill wrote and covered
sports for the New York Times for 34
years there's been a history of Michael
Jordan Tiger Woods of black athletes in
particular shine away from anything that
might you know endanger endorsements so
to that extent you know LeBron has been
refreshing as an athlete as an African
American athlete of not backing away
from it Game one of the NBA Finals is
tonight Cleveland facing the Golden
State Warriors in Oakland
James says despite the incident he will
be focused on the game
he also said basketball comes after his
family and being a role model for kids
in this country got so much mental
discipline that he can't focus without a
doubt and he's been here before
commenting on some of these so glad that
he's speaking out but it's so painful
that in 2017 you know we just had the
story in Boston last month right
baseball player on the field being
called the n-word 2017 we are still
talking about yeah and no matter the
money no matter out of the doctor you
are it does not matter that's right
thank you doings